this has been my first year in preschool
with a class of my own we've been
talking about gender and skin color and
consent it's been fabulous
no i give up i give up i feel we cannot
let a day go by at this point
without playing a clip from libs of tick
tock
my one of my favorite twitter accounts
and i and i do this not merely by the
way
to
make fun of these silly people on tick
tock or wherever that's part of it too i
won't deny it but i do it because and i
think this is the reason behind libs of
tick tock's twitter account i do it
because
i want to
remind people that the kooky ideas that
float around the academy or the float
around the elite circles of this country
have an actual effect on the ground
among
ordinary people who are just spouting
off on social media the crazy academic
theories that began in the fever dreams
of
lunatic
psychologists medical doctors theorists
people like paul money people like
wilhelm reich people like the western
marxists who had an effect on the
academy in the 20th century those ideas
among all those super sophisticated
people
with lots of books and fancy laptops
those have an effect on the culture
pretty directly so this video going
around uh tick tock
of this kooky lady she's a preschool
teacher
discussing
how elated she was to see how quickly
her preschoolers
took to radical gender theory and the
perfectly ordinary normal talk
about kids genitals
story time
this has been my first year in preschool
with a class of my own teaching
alongside another queer neurodivergent
educator and we have been rocking our
two's class we've been talking about
gender and skin color and consent and
empathy and our bodies and autonomy it's
been fabulous
but our teaching team is shifting and a
new person is being onboarded someone
with many years of experience so today
at the lunch table when the topic of
gender and genitals came up one of our
students plainly looked up and said well
i'm a girl today but i know that teacher
co isn't
no they're envy and the look on the
incoming teacher's face was priceless
she was shocked in a good way and she
just looked around at the two of us and
said this class is incredible and i am
so impressed
[Music]
we need to ban theater kids from ever
participating in society i say this as a
former theater kid so you know i did the
i
but
we got this i am calling for a complete
and total shutdown of theater kids until
we figure out what the hell is going on
because this cannot
cannot be allowed to stand the most
depressing part of this video by the way
is not
that this
woman has access to preschoolers
it's not that she is talking about
genitals at the lunch table with
preschoolers
it's not even that
it's that the older teacher comes in and
sees this
horrific offense taking place
and is shocked okay so you're like oh
good finally some
some reason here
shocked in a good way
no i give up i give up
i give up get me out of here
this is
the sort of
educational apparatus that is raising
your children and you're sending them
there when i was a kid we didn't go to
preschool i guess some people did i
didn't go to preschool when my father
was a kid people didn't really go to
kindergarten all that much
now it's you know you'd start school at
either six or five i started at five now
it seems you start at four or three some
people i kid you not i have friends and
relatives who send their kids to school
at two
and then you stay in school longer used
to be if you graduated high school you
were fine for most jobs and now it's you
have to get some associates or maybe a
bachelor's or maybe a mass i mean i know
people who can't write an english
sentence who are getting master's
degrees
which is insane you shouldn't but the
idea is you are now in this educational
apparatus to raise your children to
comport with the the dictates of the
liberal regime you're there for
forever i mean you're there for now what
20 years sometimes
not good stuff not good stuff maybe we
need to start taking a more active role
in educating people maybe when we
criticize the bizarre kooky theories of
people around the world we ought to
we can do that just fine but we ought to
criticize our own and maybe uh fix those
as well
hey i'm glad you liked that clip i hope
you liked that clip if you did just
leave a comment just say hey michael i
like that clip that'd be nice i
appreciate that it makes me feel good
uh if you have not subscribed please do
here at youtube but also to the michael
noel show podcast on apple podcast
spotify stitch or google play we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you